ahí en esta oportunidad digamos que poco
espacio para esperar la sorpresa que le
dio leon a parís anne germain pensando
en la jerarquía del barcelona el
femenina no es que estamos hablando de
un duelo muy interesante porque porque
es el equipo que ha dominado el fútbol
femenino europeo en los últimos años
estamos hablando de un olympique de lyon
que estuvo en seis de las últimas siete
finales que ganó cinco títulos entre
2016 y 2020 esto nos habla de un
potencial además muy grande de la liga
francesa que ha dominado en los últimos
tiempos y de otro lado tenemos el máximo
proyecto actual del fútbol femenino como
es el barcelona el barcelona que
evidentemente tiene a la balón de oro'
alexia putellas pero además un gran
equipo que ha logrado dominar
internamente en la liga local ganando la
copa de la reina la liga y demás que van
por ese póker de títulos y que
evidentemente también ha logrado una
comunión con los hinchas y eso es
fundamental en los procesos del fútbol
femenino estamos hablando que en este
partido entre olympique de lyon y parís
danés anger y se logró un récord de
asistencia con más de 43 mil asistentes
al estadio entonces creo que va a ser un
partido muy interesante este del 21 de
mayo en turín porque estamos hablando de
un nuevo momento del fútbol femenino
insisto el equipo que más ha dominado en
los últimos años en europa y el proyecto
más fuerte en este momento por
presupuesto por sponsors y también por
un gran grupo de jugadoras en el este el
ipyc de lyon no es la planeadora que
solía hacer en otras temporadas pero
creo que es un equipo muy eficaz y que
es logra siempre capitalizar los errores
del rival pues barcelona tiene que jugar
un equipo un partido muy inteligente
porque también ante wolfsburgo en este
partido de vuelta le costó lo perdió
evidentemente lo que había hecho en casa
y fue suficiente para llegar a la final
partidazo este como el que habíamos
pronosticado en la champions masculina
seguramente lo vamos a ver 21 de mayo
para que todos estén muy pendientes de
esta final en turín